Voy a llevaros en un viaje muy rápidamente.
Para explicar mi deseo, tendré que llevaros a un lugar
donde muchas personas no han estado, y ésto es alrededor del mundo.
Cuanto tenia 24 años, Kate Stohr y yo fundamos una organización
para que arquitectos y diseñadores se involucraran en el trabajo humanitario.
No sólo para responder a desastres naturales,
pero también para involucrarse en problemas sistémicos.
Creíamos que dónde los recursos y la experiencia son escasos,
la innovación y diseño sostenible pueden cambiar la vida de las personas.
Todo comenzó -- Yo comencé mi vida como arquitecto, o entrenando como arquitecto,
y siempre me interesó el diseño socialmente responsable,
y cómo realmente crear un impacto.
Pero cuando estudiaba arquitectura,
parecía que yo era la "oveja negra" de la familia.
Muchos arquitectos piensan que cuando diseñas,
diseñas una joya, y es una joya lo que debes querer realizar.
Pero yo sentía que al diseñar,
o mejoras, o bien empeoras
la comunidad para la cual estás diseñando.
Así que no estás solamente creando un edificio para residentes
o para las personas que lo van a usar,
sino para toda la comunidad.
En 1999, comenzamos respondiendo al problema de la crisis de vivienda
para los refugiados que regresaban a Kosovo
y yo no sabía lo que estaba haciendo, como dije, era veinteañero,
y pertenezco a la generación de Internet, así que creamos un sitio web.
Hicimos una convocatoria, y para mi sorpresa, en un par de meses
recibimos cientos de propuestas de todo el mundo.
Eso llevó a a la construcción de unos cuantos prototipos
y a experimentar con algunas ideas.
Dos años después empezamos un proyecto
para desarrollar clínicas ambulantes en África subsahariana,
en respuesta a la pandemia de VIH/SIDA.
Eso -- llevó a 550 propuestas de 53 países.
También tenemos diseñadores de todo el mundo que participan.
Y tuvimos una exposición del trabajo después.
2004 fue un año decisivo para nosotros.
Comenzamos a responder a desastres naturales
y a involucrarnos en Iran y Bam,
y también haciendo un seguimiento a nuestro trabajo en África.
Trabajando dentro de los Estados Unidos,
la mayoría de la gente piensa en la pobreza y ve el rostro de un extranjero,
pero vayan a vivir --Yo vivo en Bozeman, Montana --
suban a las planicies norteñas en las reservas de indios nativos,
o bajen a Alabama o Mississippi
antes de Katrina, y les hubiera mostrado lugares
que están en peores condiciones que muchos países en vías de desarrollo.
Así que nos involucramos y trabajamos en estos barrios de ciudad y en otras partes.
Y también otros proyectos.
en el 2005 la Madre Naturaleza nos dió una paliza.
Creo que podemos decir que el 2005 fué un año terrible
en lo que se refiere a desastres naturales.
Y debido a Internet,
y a las conexiones a blogs y demás,
a las pocas horas del tsunami, ya habíamos recaudado fondos,
involucrándonos, trabajando con las personas sobre el terreno.
Trabajamos con un par de portátiles en los primeros días,
Me llegaron 4.000 correos electrónicos de personas que necesitaban ayuda.
Así que comenzamos a meternos en proyectos ahí,
y les comentaré acerca de otros.
Y por supuesto, este año hemos respondido a Katrina,
al mismo tiempo que hacíamos un seguimiento de nuestros trabajos de reconstrucción.
Este es un breve resúmen.
En 2004 yo no podia administrar
ell número de personas que querían ayudar,
ni el número de peticiones que estaba recibiendo.
Todo llegaba a mi portátil y teléfono móvil
Así que decidimos adoptar un --
modelo de negocio de código abierto,
en el que cualquiera, en cualquier parte del mundo, pudiera comenzar un capítulo local,
e involucrarse en problemas locales.
Porque creo que no existe la Utopía.
Los problemas son locales. Las soluciones son locales.
Entonces, eso significa que,
alguien que vive en Mississippi,
sabrá más sobre Mississippi que yo. Lo que pasó fue que,
usamos "MeetUp" y otros tipo de herramientas de Internet,
y tuvimos 40 capítulos que iniciaron,
miles de arquitectos en 104 países.
Entonces, el punto principal --perdón, no soy de llevar traje,
ya sabía que me lo iba a quitar.
Bien, porque voy a hacer esto muy rápido.
En los últimos siete años, esto no se trata solamente del esfuerzo sin ánimo de lucro.
Lo que me enseñó es que se está iniciando un gran movimiento
de diseñadores socialmente responsables
que creen que este mundo se ha vuelto muy pequeño,
y que tenemos la oportunidad -- no la responsabilidad,
la oportunidad -- de involucrarnos de verdad hacia el cambio.
(Risas)
Voy a agregar eso a mi tiempo.
Lo que no sabeis es,
que tenemos estos miles de diseñadores trabajando en todo el mundo,
conectados básicamente por un sitio web, y tenemos sólo a tres empleados.
Haciendo algo, el hecho de que nadie nos dijo que no lo podíamos hacer,
lo hicimos. Esto dice algo de la ingenuidad.
Siete años después, nos hemos desarrollado al punto de tener defensores,
instigación e implementación. Abogamos por el buen diseño,
no sólo mediante talleres con estudiantes, seminarios, foros públicos,
y artículos, tenemos un libro sobre trabajo humanitario,
pero también sobre la mitigación de desastres y como lidiar con la política pública.
Podríamos hablar de FEMA, pero eso sería otra charla.
Instigación, desarrollo de ideas con las comunidades
y ONGs creando concursos de diseño de código abierto.
Arbitrando, comprometiéndonos con las comunidades
e implementando -- realmente ir a estos lugares y hacer el trabajo,
porque cuando uno inventa, no se hace realidad hasta que se construye.
Es muy importante que si estamos diseñando
y tratando de cambiar las cosas, que seamos capazes de construir el cambio.
Estos son algunos de los proyectos.
Kosovo. Esto es Kosovo en el '99. Lanzamos un concurso abierto de diseño,
y, como os conté, surgió una gran variedad de ideas,
y no se trataba de refugios de emergencia, sino de refugios transicionales
que durarían de 5 a 10 años,
que serían colocados junto al terreno en el que vivía el residente,
en el que reconstruirían su nuevo hogar.
No se trataba de imponer una arquitectura a la comunidad,
se trataba de proporcionarles las herramientas y,
el espacio para permitirles
reconstruir y crecer de la manera que ellos quisieran.
Tenemos desde lo sublime hasta lo ridículo, pero funcionaron.
Esta es una casa de cáñamo inflable. Se construyó; funciona.
Esta es una caja contenedora. Construida y funcionando.
Y toda una variedad de ideas
que no sólo tratan con la construcción arquitectónica,
pero también con problemas gubernamentales
y la idea de crear comunidades mediante redes complejas.
Así que no sólo involucramos a diseñadores, pero también
a una variedad enorme de profesionales con bases tecnológicas.
Usando escombros de casas destruidas para construir nuevas.
Usando fardos de paja para construir, creando muros de aislamiento.
Y entonces ocurrió algo excepcional en el '99.
Fuimos a África, originalmente a observar un problema de vivienda.
En tres días nos dimos cuenta que el problema no era la vivienda;
era la creciente pandemia de VIH/SIDA.
Y no eran los médicos los que nos decían esto;
eran los habitantes de las aldeas quienes nos lo decían.
Y se nos ocurrió la brillante idea de que, en lugar de que la gente
caminara 10 o 15 kilómetros para ver al médico, llevar los médicos a la gente.
Y comenzamos a hablar con la comunidad médica.
Y yo pensé, nosotros pensamos que éramos realmente brillantes, unos cracks --
se nos ocurre esta idea genial, clínicas ambulantes que --
pueden distribuirse por toda Africa subsahariana.
Y la comunidad médica de ahí dijo,
"Esto lo llevamos diciendo durante la última década. Lo sabemos, esto.
Solamente que no sabíamos cómo ilustrarlo".
Así que, de alguna manera, tomamos una necesidad existente y dimos soluciones.
Y de nuevo, surgieron una gran variedad de ideas.
Esta en particular me encanta,
porque la idea de esta arquitectura no es sólo de soluciones,
sino de crear conciencia.
Esta es una clínica hecha de kenaf. Se plantan semillas y se cultiva en un terreno,
y entonces -- esto crece más de 4 metros en un mes.
Y a la cuarta semana, los médicos vienen y cortan una zona,
colocan una estructura tensil en la parte de arriba
y cuando los médicos han terminado de tratar
y de ver a los pacientes,
se corta la clínica y se puede comer. Es una Clínica Comestible.
(Risas)
De esta manera, se está tratando con el hecho de que si se tiene SIDA
se necesita tener una buena alimentación,
y la idea es que la alimentación es tan importante
como son los antivirales.
Así que, sabeis, es una solución seria.
Ésta me encanta. La idea es que no es solo una clínica -- es un centro comunitario.
Con esto se busca establecer rutas de comercio
y motores económicos dentro de la comunidad,
para que pueda ser un proyecto auto-sostenible.
Cada uno de estos proyectos es sostenible.
Y no es porque yo sea una persona ecológica.
Es porque, si vives con cuatro dólares al día,
tienes que sobrevivir y para eso hay que ser sostenible.
Tienes que saber de donde viene tu energía.
Tienes que saber de donde vienen tus recursos.
Y tienes que mantener tus costes de mantenimiento al mínimo.
Así que se trata de tener un motor económico,
y por la noche se convierte en un cine.
No es una clínica de SIDA. Es un centro comunitario.
Pueden ver las ideas. Y estas ideas se convierten en prototipos,
y eventualmente se construyeron. En lo que va de año,
ya hay clínicas ambulantes en Nigeria y Kenia.
De ahí también desarrollamos Siyathemba, que fue un proyecto --
la comunidad vino a nosotros y nos dijo,
que el problema es que las niñas no tenían educación.
Y estamos trabajando en un lugar
donde jovencitas de entre 16 y 24 años
tienen una tasa del 50% de VIH/SIDA
Y no es porque sean promíscuas,
es porque no hay conocimiento.
Y por eso decidimos considerar la idea de los deportes y crear un centro de deportes para jóvenes
que a la vez sirviera de centro de divulgación sobre VIH/SIDA
y los entrenadores del equipo femenino también eran médicos entrenados.
Para que lentamente
se desarrollara un especie de confianza en el cuidado de la salud.
Seleccionamos a nueve finalistas,
y esos nueve finalistas se distribuyeron en toda la región,
y después la comunidad eligió su diseño.
Ellos dijeron, éste es nuestro diseño,
porque no sólo se trata de involucrar a la comunidad,
es darle poder a esa comunidad
y hacer que formen parte del proceso de reconstrucción.
El diseño ganador es este, y por supuesto,
fuimos y trabajamos con la comunidad y con los clientes.
Aquí está el diseñador. El está ahí afuera trabajando
con el primer equipo de fútbol femenino en Kwa-Zulu Natal, Siyathemba,
y ellos pueden contarlo mejor.
Video: Bueno, mi nombre es Sisi, porque trabajo en el centro Africano
Soy consultora y también soy jugadora nacional de fútbol
para Sudáfrica, Bafana Bafana,
y también juego en la Liga Vodacom para el equipo llamado Tembisa,
que ahora se llama Siyathemba.
Este es nuestro campo de juego.
Cameron Sinclair: Lo mostraré después porque se me está acabando el tiempo.
Puedo ver a Chris mirándome de reojo.
Este fue un contacto,
una reunión con alguien que quería desarrollar
el primer centro de telemedicina, en Tanzania.
Y nos conocimos, literalmente, hace un par de meses. Ya hemos desarrollado un diseño,
y el equipo está allí, trabajando en conjunto.
Fue un emparejamiento, gracias a dos personas de TED:
Cheryl Heller y Andrew Zolli,
que nos conectaron con esta increíble mujer africana.
Comenzaremos la construcción en junio, y estará listo para TEDGlobal.
Asi que cuando vengan a TEDGlobal, podrán verlo.
Pero nos conocen mejor probablemente por nuestrs trabajo en desarrollo y en respuesta a desastres naturales,
y nos hemos involucrado en muchos problemas,
como el tsunami y como el huracán Katrina.
Esto es un refugio que cuesta 370 dólares y se puede montar fácilmente.
Esto es diseño comunitario.
Un centro comunitario diseñado por la misma comunidad.
Y eso significa que nosotros vivimos y trabajamos con la comunidad,
y ellos son parte del proceso de diseño.
Los niños se involucran en la ubicación
en dónde debería estar el centro, y posteriormente,
la comunidad está entrenando adquiriendo habilidades,
y terminan construyendo el edificio con nosotros.
Aquí está otra escuela.
Esto es lo que la O.N.U. dá a estas personas para seis meses -- 12 lonas de plástico.
Esto fue en agosto. Esto fue el reemplazo,
y se supone que debía durar dos años.
Cuando cae la lluvia no escuchas otra cosa,
y en verano se está a 60 grados adentro.
Entonces dijimos, si llueve, capturemos el agua.
Cada una de nuestras escuelas tiene un sistemas de captura de lluvia, de muy bajo coste.
Una clase, tres aulas y un sistema de captura de lluvia son cinco mil dólares.
El dinero se recaudó vendiendo chocolate caliente en Atlanta.
Está construido por los padres de los niños.
Los niños están en el lugar, construyendo los edificios.
Y se inauguró hace un par de semanas,
y ahora hay 600 niños que utilizan las escuelas.
(Aplausos)
Y el desastre llegó a casa.
Hemos visto historias terribles en CNN y en Fox, etcetera,
pero nunca vemos las buenas noticias.
Esta comunidad que se unió y dijo no a esperar.
Formaron una alianza, una asociación de diversos participantes
para mapear Biloxi del Este,
para averiguar quién se estaba involucrando
Tuvimos 1.500 voluntarios reconstruyendo y rehabilitando casas.
Investigando las normativas de FEMA,
sin esperar a que ellos nos dijeran como reconstruir.
Trabajando con los residentes, sacándolos de sus casas,
para que no enfermaran. Esto es lo que ellos están arreglando por sí mismos.
Diseñando la vivienda. Esta casa estará lista en un par de semanas.
Esta es una casa rehabilitada, realizada en cuatro días.
Esto es una lavandería para una mujer que camina con andador.
Tiene 70 años. Esto es lo que dió FEMA.
600 dólares, ocurrió hace dos días.
Montamos rápidamente una estructura para el lavadero.
Está construido, funcionando y hoy arrancó su negocio,
donde lava ropa para la gente.
Estos son Shandra y los Calhouns. Son fotógrafos
que han documentado el barrio Lower Ninth durante los últimos 40 años.
Este era su hogar, estas son las fotografías que tomaron.
Y les ayudamos, trabajando con ellos para crear un edificio nuevo.
Proyectos que hemos hecho. Proyectos de los que formamos parte y apoyamos.
¿Por qué las agencias de ayuda no hacen ésto?. Esta es una tienda de la O.N.U.
Esta es la nueva tienda de la O.N.U. de este año.
Rápido de montar. Tiene una solapa, ése es el invento.
Tardaron 20 años en diseñar esto e implementarlo.
Yo tenía 12 años. Hay un problema aquí.
Por suerte no estamos sólos.
Hay cientos, y cientos y cientos
y cientos de arquitectos y diseñadores e inventores
alrededor del mundo que están involucrados en trabajo humanitario.
Más casas de cáñamo -- muy popular en Japón aparentemente.
No estoy seguro que estarán fumando.
Esto es un gancho diseñado por alguien que dijo, lo único que necesitas es una manera
de sujetar estructuras téxtiles a vigas de soporte.
Esta persona diseñó para la NASA -- ahora hace casas.
Voy a comentar ésto rápidamente,
porque sé que tengo sólo un par de minutos.
Esto es todo lo que se ha hecho en los últimos dos años.
Os mostré algo que tardó 20 años en hacer.
Y ésto es solo una parte de lo que se hizo en --
de lo que construimos el los últimos dos años.
Desde Brasil a India,
México,
China
Israel,
Palestina,
Vietnam
La edad media de un diseñador
que se involucra en este proyecto es de 32 -- es la edad que tengo yo. Así que es un joven --
Tengo que detenerme aqui, porque Arup está por aquí
y éste es el baño mejor diseñado del mundo.
Si alguna vez están en la India, vayan y usen este baño.
(Risas)
Chris Luebkeman os dirá porqué.
Estoy seguro de que es así como él queria pasar la fiesta, pero --
pero el futuro no serán ciudades de rascacielos como Nueva York,
será ésto. Y cuando ves esto, ves crisis.
Y lo que yo veo son muchos, muchos inventores.
Mil millones de personas viven en pobreza extrema.
Oímos hablar de ello todo el tiempo.
Cuatro mil millones viven en crecientes pero frágiles economías.
Uno de cada siete vive en asentamientos no planificados.
Si no hacemos nada respecto a la crísis de viviendoa que está a punto de ocurrir,
dentro de 20 años, una de cada tres personas vivirá en un asentamiento informal
o en un campo de refugiados. Mira a la izquierda, a la derecha: uno de vosotros estará ahí.
¿Cómo mejorar los condiciones de vida de 5 mil millones de personas?
Con diez millones de soluciones.
Mi deseo es desarrollar una comunidad que activamente adopte
el diseño innovador y sostenible
para mejorar las condiciones de vida de todos.
Chris Anderson: Espera, espera un momento. ¿Ése es tu deseo?
CS: Ése es mi deseo.
CA: ¡Ése es su deseo!
(Aplausos)
Comenzamos Architecture for Humanity con 700 dólares y un sitio web.
Y mira tu, Chris ha decidido darme 100.000 dólares.
¿Así que porqué no toda esta gente?
La aquitectura de código abierto es la respuesta.
Tienes a una diversa comunidad de participantes --
y no hablamos solamente de inventores y diseñadores,
hablamos del modelo de financiación.
Mi papel no es de diseñador;
soy un vínculo entre el mundo del diseño y el mundo humanitario.
Y lo que necesitamos es algo que replique lo que hago yo, globalmente,
porque no he dormido en siete años.
(Risas)
En segundo lugar ¿qué será esto?
Diseñadores quieren responder a problemas de crisis humanitaria,
pero no quieren que una compañía occidental
se aproprie de su idea con fines lucrativos.
Creative Commons ha desarrollado una licencia para países en desarrollo.
Y eso significa que un diseñador puede - el proyecto Siyathemba que mostré
fue el primero en construirse bajo una la licencia Creative Commons.
En cuanto esté constuido, cualquiera en África u otra nación en desarrollo
podrá tener acceso a los documentos de construcción y replicarlos gratuitamente.
(Aplausos)
¿Entonces por qué no dar la oportunidad a los diseñadores de hacer esto,
pero all mísmo tiempo proteger sus derechos, aquí?
Queremos tener una comunidad donde se puedan subir ideas,
y esas ideas puedan probarse en terremotos, inundaciones,
en todo tipo de ambientes austeros. Esto es importante porque
no quiero esperar al siguiente huracán Katrina para saber si mi casa funciona.
Será demasiado tarde. Necesitamos hacerlo ahora.
Haciéndolo globalmente.
Y quiero que todo esto funcione en muchos idiomas.
Cuando piensas en el rostro de un arquitecto, la mayoría se imagina un señor blanco y canoso.
Yo no veo eso. Yo lo que veo es el rostro del mundo.
Quiero que todos en el mundo entero,
puedan participar en este diseño y desarrollo.
La idea de concursos surgidos de la necesidad -- el Premio X para el otro 98%,
si quieren llamarlo así.
También querémos buscar formas de crear enlaces
y juntar a patrocinadores.
Y la idea de integrar fabricantes -- laboratorios en cada país.
Cuando oigo hablar del portátil de 100 dólares
y que va a educar a todos los niños,
eduquemos a todos los diseñadores del mundo. Pongamos a uno en cada favela,
en cada barriada, porque sabes qué,
la innovación ocurrirá.
Y yo necesito saberlo. Se le llama transferencia.
Hablamos de transferencia de tecnologías. Escribo para Worldchanging,
y lo que hemos estado hablando es que,
Aprendo más sobre el terreno de lo que jamás aprendí aquí.
Así que tomemos esas ideas, adaptémoslas y podremos usarlas.
Estas ideas deben ser adaptables,
pueden ser -- deben tener el potencial para evolucionar,
deberían ser desarrolladas por todas las naciones del mundo
y ser útiles para cada nación del mundo. ¿Qué se necesita?
Debería haber una hoja. No tengo tiempo de leer esto,
porque me van a echar.
CA: Déjalo ahí por un momento.
CS: Bueno ¿qué se necesita? Sois listos.
Requiere un gran esfuerzo de calculación, porque yo quiero que --
Quiero que desde cualquier portátil en cualquier parte del mundo se pueda conectar al sistema
y no solo participar en el desarrollo de estos diseños,
sino utilizar los diseños. También, un proceso de revisión de los diseños.
Quiero que todos los ingenieros Arup del mundo revisen
y se aseguren de que estamos haciendo cosas que se mantengan de pie,
porque esos tios son los mejores del mundo. Enchufe.
Y para que sepais, yo quiero estos -- debo decir,
que tengo dos portátiles y uno de ellos está ahí
y contiene 3000 diseños. Si se daña ese portatil ¿qué pasaría?
Entonces es importante tener estas ideas probadas, subidas a la web,
fácil de usar, fácil de acceder.
Mi mamá una vez dijo, no hay nada peor que hablar demasiado y no llevar pantalones.
(Risas)
Estoy harto de hablar sobre el cambio.
Sólo puedes realizarlo haciéndolo.
Hemos cambiado las guías de FEMA. Hemos cambiado la política pública.
Hemos cambiado la respuesta internacional -- en base a la construcción de cosas.
Para mi, lo importante es que creemos un conducto real
para la innovación, la innovación libre.
Piensa en la cultura libre -- esto es la innovación libre.
Alguien dijo ésto hace un par de años.
Le daré puntos a quien lo conozca,
Creo que se adelantó unos 25 años, así que hagámoslo.
Gracias.
(Aplauso)